hey andy how are you i'm doing really
well how are you i'm good
congratulations you know uh in this film
you're reliving the same day over and
over again basically how we've been
spending the last year for a lot of us
um so have you taken up any new passions
and what have you been doing during
lockdown um well in the beginning i
think i was a lot more proactive and you
know
my wife and i were like learning how to
mix cocktails and cook and all this
stuff and
since then it's just like keep our
daughter alive
and entertained and that's really like
the only thing
that's become not just uh not just the
passion but also the
the livelihood it's every every second
of every day it seems but it's great
and what's the key thing of to keeping
your daughter alive food
food is the main one i mean it's a trick
question right
you have to feed them and then they have
to get some sleep at some point but
other than that
you know they're just gonna do whatever
they want awesome thanks so much
congratulations
thank you very much appreciate it when
you sat down to develop the film
what were some of your inspirations
regarding you know favorite movies on
the whole repeating the same day
genre and secondly would you be up for a
sequel
maybe getting back into the loop
i'm always up for a sequel to anything
so you can just assume i'm up for a
sequel anything i've ever done i'll do a
sequel if there's a script that that's
good
um am i going to write it no i don't
know but if andy sierra's like i've got
a great idea for a sequel i'm there
um uh you know i mean the obvious
references were
is groundhog day um but you know when we
first started working
on this movie with andy and max the only
other one i was really aware of was edge
of tomorrow which i also
loved like one of my honestly one of my
favorite sci-fi movies
period i just love that movie um and
then
you know we tried to keep those in mind
as we were sort of like trying to
make sure that we were you know
letting the audience know that we were
aware that we're not like inventing this
that we're trying to take it into a new
direction and take it maybe a step
further even because
we we're all in the same viewing you
know uh
experience together as people who watch
everything and
uh during the time that we started
developing it and then we got a green
lit then russian doll came out
and that's you know my friends who made
that and i watched that and i was like
oh man this is
good are we toast uh and then we just
kept
pushing forward and then you know people
are like oh like happy death day and i
was like
but um it turns out it's just a cool
genre you know it's uh it's something
that
if you have a new and unique take on it
i'm gonna watch it because it's cool
it's fun it's there's something really
gratifying about watching people go
through the trials of it and
and as long as it's a unique take i
think people are still interested so
uh i'm glad we didn't bail on it but it
was definitely discussed a few times
because we were like oh
are there too many of these the thing
that i want to know about is there's
one scene in the film that makes me
laugh every time you're
i see it and it's the damn arrow scene
how many takes was it
and just give me give me some sort of
scoop because
that's hysterical every time i watch it
uh well thank you
i will say when i first read the script
that was the moment that i
decided i wanted to do the movie so i
think we're on the same page there
um we probably did five or six takes
it we like we kind of knew
that we had what we needed pretty
quickly
um and you know there's a little bit of
trickery in terms of getting the arrow
in and all that kind of stuff so that
you know you split the cut and that kind
of thing but generally speaking
it was like we're out in the middle of
the desert i'm screaming at the top of
my lungs it's like two degrees
uh and you know chris and i are like
rolling around on a boulder
and the snake wrangler's like i can't
see there might be snakes
so it looked like jk had
too much fun shooting that arrow at you
man
the whole thing with jk he from the from
the jump he texted me can't wait to
torture you
that's how he told me he was doing the
movie uh so i knew that he was gonna
lean into it but that's fine because
everyone knows i met